[Musica]
ben trovati in realtà non vivo in india
ma in sardegna e come tutti i sardi
tendo a portarmi pezzetti di casa sono
felice che siate qui e siete in tanti
molti di voi vivono come noi
l'esperienza dell'attraversamento del
mare no si parte da giovanissimi per
andare a studiare altrove e poi come
capita si ritorna è stato un anno
complesso è stato un anno bellissimo
come sempre ritrovarsi in un luogo dove
l'esperienza del prendere tempo
respirare un attimo è un'esperienza
privilegiata
siete mai arrivati in sardegna quando
arrivati in sardegna dopo una lunga
traversata a volte 12 ore a volte un po
di più di nave a volte più velocemente
in aereo si atterra si arriva si approda
è qualcosa di straordinario ci colpisce
immediatamente
a un profumo diverso
l'aria ha un profumo di armida il team
selvatico
il mio microfono si sta lamentando
l'aria il profumo del rosmarino della
lavanda al profumo di tutte quelle erbe
che trasformano la vista di una terra
che sembra brulla dall'alto e che invece
è un vero e proprio paradiso o il
fattivo noi sardi cresciamo nel profumo
non ci rendiamo sempre colto non ce ne
rendiamo
continuamente conto ma siamo circondati
da una dimensione olfattiva permanente
che viaggia nel nostro dna e che ci fa
pare che questo sia un privilegio al
quale non possiamo fare a meno
quando si arriva in sardegna un
abbraccio che diventa sogno proprio come
il cinema come i film sul grande schermo
in sala è un sogno che ti fa venire
voglia di continuare a nutrirsi di
possibilità
quando si arriva dopo un anno in cui le
sale sono state chiuse i viaggi sono
stati bloccati la possibilità di vacanza
di esplorazione e di mondo altro magari
profumato è una grandissima gioia
e allora si preparano i bagagli
e si preparano il must della valigia
esplorare andare addirittura dentro i
fondali marini e scoprire che quella
acqua cristallina
in realtà un altro mondo
questo è un oggetto che nasce dal genio
umano ci ha dato la possibilità di
vivere un'esperienza in cinemascope
sott'acqua è nata da designer ingegneri
oceanografi indagini qualitative di
mercato cosa cercano i consumatori per
andare in vacanza dove vogliono arrivare
vogliono arrivare sotto più a fondo e se
possibile vedere tutto come nei grandi
film western e allora quando ci siamo
riusciti abbiamo potuto perfino
respirare sott'acqua è stata una
straordinaria liberazione
marzo 20 20
bergamo brescia
respirare non è più un privilegio
respirare non è più possibile
ci sono tante persone che non respirano
più
un professore ex primario della
valtrompia
renato favero sta cercando una soluzione
non può credere che tutta la sua vita
dedicata alla medicina si fermi così
credo accidentalmente me lo immagino
mentre circa tre manuali dell'università
gli ultimi aggiornamenti medici gli
articoli cerca una soluzione e incappa
nella borsa delle vacanze e trova questa
diviene un'illuminazione il genio nella
contraddizione della morte nella paura
della fine
esplode e la tecnologia si sposa con la
creatività più pura quella che crea il
gesto dell'arte
contatta dei giovanissimi ingegneri una
start up e dice dobbiamo sostituire il
boccaglio con una valvola stampiamo lo
in 3d vediamo se riusciamo a trasformare
questa da oggetto del paradiso dei
vacanzieri ad uno strumento di vita e
così decine e decine centinaia di
persone si salvano attaccandosi ad un
respiratore con delle valvole create da
un giovane gruppo di ingegneri
quello che era diventato lo strumento
per farci diventare da turisti ad
esploratori diventa un salvavita diventa
la possibilità di ritrovare il piacere
del respiro
per noi che facciamo arte questa è
esattamente la quintessenza dell'umanità
noi siamo capaci di mettere insieme noi
che facciamo cinema
creiamo il magico con la tecnologia le
persone con le loro idee trovano solo
attraverso degli strumenti la mediazione
ed eccoci qua finalmente c'è speranza
quella scritta che sembrava svettare in
tutti gli ospedali di tali e poi
progressivamente l'azione popolazione
nel mondo lasciate ogni speranza voi che
entrate è ritornata a brillare in noi
speranza speranza il latino spese
un'origine straordinarie il sanscrito ci
dice spa
ironia della sorte più che benessere è
un tendere verso una meta noi siamo
soggetti persone che tendono sempre
nella propria esistenza verso una meta
attivamente non aspettiamo impariamo ad
aspettare ma vogliamo arrivare a quella
meta ed ecco che dopo mesi di
claustrofobia di chiusura dove però a
noi del cinema è andata bene perché ne
abbiamo visti tanti di film serie tv
abbiamo cominciato a moltiplicare i
dispositivi domestici le strade erano
chiuse ma in fondo io oggi già sono
felice perché sono qui in una sala
cinematografica
e allora ricominciamo a viaggiare
ricominciamo a cercare la possibilità di
scoprire meravigliarci
localmente perché ci sono ancora dei
problemi e dobbiamo ovviamente limitare
gli spostamenti al turismo cosiddetto
nazionale cosiddetto regionale e quindi
noi italiani riscopriamo di vivere in un
paese straordinario souvenir vita di
quanti di noi hanno conquistato di nuovo
la vecchia sfera del desiderio da
bambini c'è la portavano in genere le
zie spesso zitelle che volevano
ricordarci che loro sì che erano andate
a venezia pisa a roma e noi da bambini
guardavamo questo la meraviglia d'italia
straordinari avamposti di creazione
umana architetture chiese meravigliosi
punti raccolti sotto vetro è uno dei
primi momenti in cui i bambini scoprono
di poter essere crudeli
quella che è una struttura armonica può
diventare caos e quindi quel
meraviglioso ricordo souvenir di tali
che in realtà se ci pensate è
straordinariamente stereotipato perché
via in fondo quanti di voi guardano
esattamente che cosa c'è dentro
diventa un perfetto simbolo di che cosa
stiamo diventando
noi riusciamo a creare delle
meravigliose sfere di cristallo dove
mettiamo sotto vetro le nostre città la
nostra creazione la nostra vita e perché
no anche il nostro esistere fateci caso
c'è poca natura in questa sfera di
cristallo
la stessa neve e ci tengo molto a dirlo
è sintetica è creata chimicamente e
spesso sono delle meravigliose
brillantine che inquinano che alterano
l'equilibrio di quell'oceano di quel
mare da cui io sono scappata da
ragazzina ma poi continua relazionarmi
ed a cui
respiro qui dentro per creare la
dimensione olfattiva dobbiamo andare in
laboratorio prendere esempio dalla
natura e ricostruire chimicamente i
profumi della terra i profumi del mare i
profumi del vento ma noi siamo già
immersi nel profumo è che ce lo siamo
dimenticati se lo metti sotto vetro
perché sei convinto che la tecnologia
possa davvero risolvere tutto possa
davvero controllare tutto anche quando
tu entri in casi dice alex aria di
sardegna parte il dispositivo della
dell'ossigenazione della stanza e tuo
improvvisamente sei tornato a casa eh no
cari miei non è così che funziona
io ci tengo al miglioramento di mirto il
mirto era una pianta sacra gli dei ma
sapete a quali ad afrodite a venere
amore è bella
è una pianta che ha una meravigliosa
capacità nella nostra cultura di genova
mente noi sardi lo sapete siamo un
pochino antichi preistorici ci dicono a
volte anche un po bassetti
per noi questo è il segno di una
famiglia che dura se tu arrivi in una
casa da una famiglia ea fuori dal
giardino una pianta di mirto
tecnicamente quella famiglia è lì da
tanto qualcuno ha abitato quella casa da
tanto tempo è una pianta che ci mette il
suo tempo come in sardegna le cose
cambiano lentamente però si prende il
suo spazio si radica nel terreno e crea
questa meravigliosa sensazione di
fiducia e dubbi del giardiniere c'è
scritto quando arrivi in un terreno in
un giardino con il mirto ti senti solido
senti che ci è passato il tempo e che ci
è voluta anche poca acqua ma tantissima
luce e la pianta che ricordatevelo
ridere regalata ai matrimoni per
garantire se condita alla coppia quindi
una pianta generati a
quando io penso a che cosa significhi
per l'essere umano e il 20 50
io spero che riusciremo ancora una volta
a creare con grande genialità
idee che possano trasformare lo spazio è
la nostra percezione del respiro per
farci diventare nuovi esploratori sempre
sorretti dal gioco della meraviglia
della scoperta
con una tecnologia che certamente ci
aiuta a conoscere chi siamo e dove
andremo ma che non mette sotto vuoto la
natura perché guardate che succede
eravamo convinti di avere controllato
tutto c'è stato ben detto stamattina
eravamo certi di avere misurato
analizzato trascritto tutti i nostri
numeri sono lì che ci dicono che siamo
perfettamente capaci di guardare
l'universo di comprenderlo
certamente
ma quella comprensione quel certifico
quel rapporto con la scienza non può
prescindere dal senso di meraviglia che
il nostro essere umano ha viceversa bloc
che l'essere umano è mosso da speranza è
utopia e sono le forze che spingono in
avanti
allora noi
io spero
ascolteremo il nostro cuore la nostra
mente la nostra creazione impareremo
abbiamo fatto con la serialità americana
per tutte le questioni di di mento della
tecnica e dei codici delle scene del
crimine forza siamo diventati esperti
tutte le possibili sfaccettature
dell'accesso ad una scena d'omicidio
eppure ci dimentichiamo quanto sia
importante
ritornare a respirare il privilegio di
vivere in un età profumato il privilegio
di essere immersi è parte di una più
grande dimensione dentro un mondo che ci
accoglie
esiste un bellissimo
che è il saluto dei navaho
quando si incontrano quando entrano il
sole quando cominciano la loro giornata
si augurano
cammina nella bellezza io spero che non
nel 2050 respireremo bellezza grazie
[Applauso]